sie klingt wie ein bedrohlicher
hornissenschwarm doch sie rettet leben
die drohne ferngesteuert vom boden hier
ist sie willkommen
hier wo alles so friedlich aussieht doch
in diesem idyll spielt sich zu dieser
jahreszeit täglich ein horrorfilm aber
in den dichten wiesen legen rehe ihre
neu geborenen tiere ab das gras bietet
schutz vor füchsen luchsen und anderen
feinden
doch der größte feind ist wie immer der
mensch in den ersten zwei wochen ihres
lebens kennen die tiere kein
fluchtverhalten sie liegen
zusammengekauert und warten instinktiv
ab was passiert wenn die angst noch so
groß ist
dann beginnt der horrorfilm jedes mal
auf die gleiche weise ein landwirt mit
seine wiese
dass die scharfen klingen seiner
maschine nicht nur das gras zerschneiden
ist ihm durchaus bewusst
doch nicht jeder macht sich die mühe die
wiese feuer abzusuchen
und selbst wenn viele tiere bleiben
trotz akribischer suche im gras
versteckt
wenn alles gemäht ist wird die tragödie
sichtbar zwischen mai und juli kommen
jahr für jahr schätzungsweise 100.000
rehkitze unter die mähmaschinen in herz
weh das tut einem richtig leid aber man
kann man kann es nur ging ich machen das
geht nicht um sogleich versorgen die
einen reden dann treu hat sich an also
das ist desto sowie die jäger
kritisieren der tierschutz komme bei
einigen landwirten zu kurz sie würden
nach der devise verfahren
zeit ist geld die aufgabe die
verpflichtung hier flächen abzusuchen
liegt der eindeutig in der
landwirtschaft weil derjenige der hier
eben diese gefahrenquelle schafft hat
die gesetzliche voraussetzung
dementsprechend hier sollte mein
beispiel rehkitze diese forfour methode
beziehungsweise vor verletzungen zu
schützen
doch die jäger wissen auch große flächen
sicher absuchen das ist so gut wie
unmöglich bislang jedenfalls rettung
kommt nun genau von hier aus der luft
sie haben das patent rezept ein team von
elektroingenieuren sucht die wiese in
der sie rege zu vermuten
mit hilfe einer drohne ab viel
ausgeklügelte technik kommt zum einsatz
bei der die drohne meist selbstständig
arbeitet zunächst legen die ingenieure
fest welches areal abgesucht wird dann
geht es los und zwar ziemlich schnell
eine größe von zwei fußballfeldern in
zehn minuten kein problem
die drohne hat zwei augen in form einer
infrarot und einer farbkamera die
infrarotkamera spürt durch den wärme
unterschied lebewesen in der wiese auf
mit der farbkamera lässt sich dann
bestimmen ob es sich wirklich um ein reh
handelt sobald die männer wissen wo
genau in der wiese das tier steckt kann
es mit hilfe eines gerätes dass die
koordinaten empfängt in der wiese
gefunden werden sind jungtiere jedoch
älter als zwei wochen verharren sie
nicht mehr gedruckt in der wiese sie
rennen meist zusammen mit ihrer mutter
davon
doch selbst wenn die tiere liegen
bleiben die gefahr für sie ist noch
nicht vorbei denn häufig vergeht
zwischen auffinden und abnehmen eine
gewisse zeit was also tun wenn die
gefundenen tiere in die wiese zurück
laufen
deshalb wollen die männer jetzt direkt
an den tieren peilsender an bringen die
den landwirt davor bewahren die tiere zu
töten
wiedergefunden werden die rehkitze mit
hilfe von lesegeräten die an der
landwirtschaftlichen maschine montiert
sind und dem landwirt ein signal geben
dass in unmittelbarer nähe ein rehkitz
liegt in der zukunft könnte also jeder
traktor eine hightech maschine werden
ausgestattet mit einer atem war radar
achtung rehkitz in der wiese